that willful blindness and woeful um
underpreparedness is basically leaving
our future Generations asking
[Music]
WTF we're going to talk about the very
difficult task of embodying the future
in the present and the difficulties that
democracies face which are significant
with tackling long-term problems it's
always been a difficulty democracies
have faced how do you do something the
consequences of which will be only
fulfilled many years hence perhaps
decades hence in the present it's a
genuine problem when most democracies
don't tackle it particularly well and we
will explore some of the ways in which
that happens or doesn't happen what we
might do about it how we might do it
better I've got with me three people who
I think are up to that very difficult
task I've just set um Hillary Graves is
a professor of philosophy at the
University of Oxford and a Trailblazer
in the field of effective altruism and
Hillary was the uh founding director of
the global priorities
Institute I have Lord Jonathan sumption
with me he's an author political
commentator and most decorated lawyer of
his generation and Jonathan sat as a
judge on the Supreme Court between 2012
and 2018 and appeared as a barrister for
many many things one of which was Hunton
inquiry and Sophia how is a sustainable
Futures and wellbeing adviser who has a
great distinction of being the very
first person to hold the role of future
Generations commissioner in Wales so the
an attempt to embody in policy uh the
claims of future Generations so let me
open up by coming to Hillary for opening
remarks thank you um okay so if the
question we want to ask is something
like to what extent should current
policy be guided by considerations of
the far future where by the far future
we might mean um consequences of current
policy that only come to pass say more
than a 100 years from now I think there
are two really quite distinct sets of
issues that we face and it's helpful to
start by separating those um the two
sets of issues I'm thinking of
separating are the ethical principles
and the empirical issues so the ethical
questions will be things like to what
extent do further future people matter
morally for the purpose of current decis
making what responsibilities do we owe
to future people to what extent can we
permissibly be partial towards the
present generation the empirical issues
are to to do with the challenges of
predicting and affecting the further
future so one line of thought in the
empirical bucket goes something like oh
but come on it's so uh basically
impossible to predict what the effects
of anything we do now will be on time
scales of centuries that the whole
project of trying to make current policy
with an eye to the further future future
is completely hopeless so those are the
empirical challenges having separated
those two things I guess I'll use the
remainder of my 3 minutes by trying to
say a little bit more about the ethical
ones my own expertise being as a a moral
philosopher Derek parfett one of the
most renowned moral philosophers of the
20th century invites us to consider the
following thought experiment suppose
that you are out in the forest on a walk
one day and you accidentally break a
glass bottle suppose hopefully nobody
here would do this suppose that you
decide to bury this glass bottle in a
shallow bottle grave knowing that
sometime in the future a child playing
in the forest will be injured will cut
thems on this glass parfett then asked
us to consider whether it makes a
difference to the morality of that
action whether the child in question is
going to find the bottle tomorrow or
instead in a thousand years time the
point of this thought experiment is
supposed to bring out the thought that
if you really could be equally certain
that a child would be harmed in a
thousand years as you could be that a
child will be harmed in exactly the same
way tomorrow there is no morally
relevant difference between those two
cases if you agree with that intuition
then you think okay in principle further
future people matter ethically to just
ex the extent that present people do the
issues if we're thinking that maybe
current policy should be mostly focused
on the the nearer future can only be
along the more empirical side maybe we
are just in fact completely hopelessly
uncertain what CH what children will be
up to whether they will still be playing
in forests in a thousand years time
whereas we might have very good grounds
for thinking that that's going to happen
tomorrow um maybe I'll flag one more
thing that I think sometimes gets people
hung up and then perhaps going in a
wrong direction on the ethical issues
sometimes people are gripped by the
thought that well but hang on this stuff
about caring about future people people
who haven't even been born yet doesn't
make sense because those future people
don't exist it doesn't make sense to
care about people who don't exist I
think this is just a a confusing way of
using the word exists it might be
helpful to think of time on an analogy
with space you can picture the universe
as a four-dimensional block there are
the familiar three dimensions the three
dimensions of space time is just the
fourth dimension so when we're talking
about a person who will exist in a
thousand years time you can rephrase
that as thinking about a person who does
exist in this four-dimensional block
just located somewhere different from us
so on that way of thinking talking about
the morality of affecting for our future
people is very similar set of issues to
talking about the morality of affecting
people who are far away from us in space
um okay maybe I'll stop there well Hill
thank you I mean you set out a very uh
interesting way which the ethical
demands will lead us to have empirical
answers to the questions of how we
respond um Jonathan sumption what's your
opening thoughts on this this dialogue
between the short and the long term well
I think it's at the same time very
simple and very difficult obviously we
have a moral respons responsibility to
Future Generations uh we live in society
and by definition that that means that
we have duties to entities uh which are
larger than ourselves family Nation
Humanity these are all entities with a
future longer than our own but that's
the easy bit um because this is a
practical and not just a moral issue and
I agree with the point that just been
made about that being two buckets first
of all we have to recognize our
limitations we cannot know what will be
the interest of people more than a short
time ahead a generation maybe two or
three generations probably not more
except in the simplest of cases like
broken glass bottles um the perceptions
and priorities of our grandchildren will
depend on intervening technological
developments and on changing moral
priorities many of which we simply will
not be able to anticipate history is
actually full uh of blueprints for the
future all of which have only one thing
in common they all turned out to be
wrong now secondly looking at the
Practical side um democracy is also to a
large extent a moral principle and the
future uh has no
votes future Generations are not part of
the existing
poity that doesn't mean to say that we
are justified in ignoring their
interests but it is a real practical
issue climate change is the obvious test
issue and much the most important one
most policy options for dealing with
climate change involve higher costs uh
or reduced consumption or a mixture of
the two Democratic electorates are not
going to accept readily either of those
things unless they are introduced
gradually persuasively
tactfully people living in the country
many of them in old houses are not going
to agree to measures that will cost them
£20,000 Upfront for new heating systems
that still leave them shivering people
who depend on their cars to get to work
because of Lifetime lifestyle choices
made often decades ago or to take their
children to school just can't be told uh
uh to wise up and buy a different car or
none at all and as the mayor of London
is now discovering sanctimonious
hectoring about the imminent end of the
world is not likely to change these
basic human instincts about our fellow
citizens you will not persuade people to
agree with you by disruptive
demonstrations uh designed to make their
lives a misery so unless we abandon
democracy in favor of some form of
authoritarian government we have to
compromise between our own interests and
those of our
grandchildren
jonan thank you it's interesting isn't
it how the a long-term question comes
all the way down to the Oxbridge
byelection this is part of modern
politics immediately it's a symptom of
something much larger yeah absolutely
Sophia well our systems of politics and
governance are inherently uh shortterm
and there's very little Interest really
in trying to to change that it's a bit
like turkeys voting for for Christ
really um and I think that that is um
one of the biggest challenges that we
face and is why we're in this kind of
existential threat particularly around
climate change um not just climate
however some of our um our ways of life
some of the things that we hold very
dear are really um at significant risk
because of our failure to think long
term so institutions like the National
Health Service um the way in which that
is absolutely creepy
um under the pressure the way in which
everything is directed just in the short
term chucking more money at the problem
not enough money um to deal with the
waiting list and not actually getting
upfront of any of those issues asking
the question why are people on waiting
list in the first place what are the
holistic long-term public policy
Solutions um that we might want to put
in place to deal with some of that and
actually um if we thought longterm and
if we thought joined up um transport
policy is a public health policy because
actually if you think about transport
policy as um uh delivered in a way which
reduces air pollution which encourages
people to use public transport active
travel walking and cycling which
encourages communities to be more
connected in those ways those are all
factors which are the wider longer term
determinants of health so I don't think
you can split these things up but
governments and policy makers are
inherently really bad at doing that and
I think that there are uh some
particular issues uh there I think that
um government is and policy makers are
willfully blind to issues the wicked
issues that they don't want to deal with
we have put more and you know we we can
say okay going a 100 200 a thousand
years into the future we don't know and
um your right to a degree Michael
futurists don't often get um things
exactly right I was looking at some uh
predictions from 1923 for the year
2023 um a little while ago and uh some
of the headlines there were were things
like we should worry because women will
be shaving their heads and men will be
wearing curls um also they were saying
that we would all now in 2023 only be
working a 4-Hour day owing to the work
of electricity um and they also said
that we would all be using utensils made
from Pulp and uh humans would be living
um at least 100 years and in some cases
up to 200 years now that's not exactly
right but you can see some of those
signal signals there the way in which we
have a completely different view of
gender and identity for example um the
world's biggest trial of the um of of a
reduced working week has just been
completed successfully um you know we
are all living longer not quite to 200
years yeah and actually plate um life
expectancy at a UK uh level and you know
perhaps we're ending our love affair
with plastic so there are some signals
there but I think the key issue is we
don't even bother to look for those
signals and Beyond not even looking for
those signals we don't even we are
willfully blind to the absolute blatant
evidence which is front in front of us
so we have put more carbon into our
atmosphere since the UN published their
first framework of evidence on climate
change since Al Gore published his first
Inconvenient Truth we have willfully
done more damage since that time we are
woefully unprepared for the steps that
we now need to take so yes we are in a
position where people are bulked at you
know I'm used to driving my car I can't
afford a heat pump and um and so on but
that is because of the woeful inadequacy
of public policy to have actually got up
front of those issues 10 15 20 years ago
and so that willful blindness and woeful
um underpreparedness is basically
leaving our future Generations asking
WTF the podcast talks debates courses
and articles
visit the Institute of Art and ideas
click the link on screen now
to.tv